jetzt ist es an der zeit dass politik
über sich hinauswächst dass ihr zukunft
gestalten
das ist mein angebot das ist unser
angebot dafür treten wir an ich glaube
die die die wahl von annalena baerbock
machte auch deutlich dass die grünen
keine andere wahl hatten als sich auch
sie festzulegen weil es einfach die
bessere lösung ist
sie hat zwei eigenschaften in der
derzeitigen konstellation die einfach
für sie sprechen einmal ist sie die
einzige frau in dem ganzen bewerberfeld
es wäre irgendwie eine ironie der
geschichte gewesen wenn die grünen in
dem augenblick wo sie eine frau
aufstellen könnten ist nun gerade nicht
tun dass das hätte ich nicht verstanden
und das zweite ist sie hat erfahrung in
ostdeutschland insofern setzt sie da
eine tradition fort die die grünen immer
wieder beachtet haben dass sie eben
nicht nur die die westdeutsche seite der
grünen bedenkt sondern auch die
ostdeutsche sie kommt zwar nicht aus
ostdeutschland aber sie hat er sehr viel
erfahrung gesammelt insofern gesprächen
diese zwei dinge einfach für annalena
baerbock eine grüne kanzlerin kandidatur
steht für ein neues verständnis von
politischer führung entschieden und
transparent lernfähig und selbstkritisch
ich bin aber trotzdem skeptisch dass man
dass all das was bislang passiert ist
als maßstab dafür nehmen kann was jetzt
noch kommt also jetzt beginnt überhaupt
erst der wahlkampf ist beginnt auch
überhaupt erstmal die kandidatur und man
wird dann sehen wie sich frau berg da
und da wesentlich härteren bedingungen
schlagen kann und wir sind ja noch nicht
fertig mit dem ganzen bewerberfeld es
gibt ja noch den den kandidaten der
union auch davon hängt einiges ab für
die grünen
also ich bin nach wie vor skeptisch dass
tatsächlich dieser diese
kanzlerkandidatur auch zum erfolg führen
wird
ich glaube die grüne prozess heute
einerseits schnell ja wohl aber ich
glaube das wird es da einfach mehr mühe
gegeben aber am ende wird man sehen wie
es bei den menschen ankommt ist wenn man
dann letztlich abwägen und 10 ende
september also zunächst mal ist es ja
kurios dass bei den grünen harmonie
herrscht und bei der union ein hauen und
stechen ist eigentlich hätte man das
umgekehrt erwartet wenn man sich aber es
rechte sieht bei der union war es schon
immer schwierig ein kanzler kandidaten
aufzustellen weil es einfach zwei
parteien sind die da miteinander zu tun
haben und es hat eigentlich keine
kanzlerkandidatur gegeben bislang wo
alles friede freude eierkuchen war also
es war immer mit schwierigkeiten
verbunden
die grünen halten es sich jetzt sehr
zugute dass sie jetzt das harmonische
bild liefern
aber eigentlich ist der anspruch der
grünen ja genau das was die union
praktiziert nämlich ein durchaus streit
iges demokratisches verfahren zu wählen
und davon kann man den grünen überhaupt
keine rede sagen was alles nicht geht
das haben wir jetzt in den letzten
jahren genug gehört
aber es zählt jetzt was alles geht was
alles möglich ist